KORY JEFFREY:
Welcome, everybody.
We are on site at Founder
World in San Francisco.
I'm joined in the studio
right now by Michael.
He is the VP of
Mobile at UserTesting.
Thanks for joining me, Michael.
MICHAEL MACE: My pleasure.
KORY JEFFREY: So let's start
with what UserTesting is all
about.
MICHAEL MACE: We are a really,
really, really, really,
fast way to get user feedback
on an app or website.
You come to our site, you
define the demographics
you need, the questions you
want people to answer, the tasks
that you want them to perform.
And if it's an app or website,
you upload your build to us
or give us the
URL for the place.
We then deploy it
out to our panel.
They video themselves
doing what you've
asked for, so you get audio
and video of the screen
and of them talking.
It's on a mobile device.
We capture taps and swipes
and stuff like that.
And then it gets sent back
to you so you can watch it.
The turnaround time can
be as low as an hour.
KORY JEFFREY: Wow.
MICHAEL MACE: So it lets you get
user feedback within a design
sprint.
So you can do a new
build in the morning,
you can then send it
out over lunch time
and by the time you
get back from lunch,
you're starting to
get those videos.
So really, really fast
feedback on usability
issues, or do they
understand stuff,
or other things like that.
KORY JEFFREY: Those
videos-- are they bite size?
Is there any way to
avoid data overload?
MICHAEL MACE: So if you want,
you can do it all yourself.
You come and define the test
and you watch all the videos,
and that's fine.
If you want, we can
do all that for you.
So we'll watch the videos,
we'll pick out the highlights,
and we'll explain--
OK here's the problem.
Here are three little
30 second clips.
So it's basically whichever way
you want to use the service.
It's more expensive if
you have it full service,
it's less expensive
if it's self service.
KORY JEFFREY: So how does
that scale for you guys?
Obviously having to,
within an hour or two,
be able to turn that around?
You would need a lot of testers.
Where do you source those?
How do you do that?
MICHAEL MACE: A lot of it has
been through part-time work
boards and other sorts of places
where we get word of mouth.
So we haven't had to
advertise very much.
It's kind of built
up itself over time.
The company's about
eight years old,
so we've had the luxury of being
able to grow it organically
over time.
And we've got about a million
respondents available now,
so it's turned into
a pretty big thing.
We do thousands
of tests per week.
KORY JEFFREY: Based mostly in
the US or all around the world?
MICHAEL MACE: English
speaking countries.
So US, UK-- we're starting
to expand other places.
We can do testing in
India, for instance.
So if somebody needs
a particular country,
we can usually do some
custom recruiting for that.
KORY JEFFREY: Having run
eight years' worth of tests
and seeing all of this
stuff, you must see a lot
of interesting tidbits that
would be really helpful
for entrepreneurs as
they think about this.
Can you share some of those?
MICHAEL MACE: Sure.
A couple of greatest
hits, I guess.
One would be-- never assume that
an icon or a particular word
is going to be
intuitive to your users
just because it's
intuitive to your team.
You have no idea how many
weird icon designs we've
seen on buttons where
the designers think,
oh it'll be obvious that you
push this in order to do that.
And when the users
get to it, it's
just like, what in the world
am I supposed to do here?
KORY JEFFREY: OK.
MICHAEL MACE: So my
personal recommendation--
I know it's not pretty, but I
think the only two icons that
are universally recognized
on mobile devices
are the little magnifying
glass means search,
and the question
mark means help.
Everything else, including the
hamburger menu, a lot of people
will misunderstand.
And so maybe you put
words underneath.
Even though it's
not as pretty, it
makes your app look a
little more cluttered.
The question is, are
you shooting for pretty
or are you shooting for usable?
When you have to choose, I
think you want to go for usable.
The other thing we've
been seeing a lot lately,
that I think is a
really important one,
is we are now able to
test out in the wild.
So just recently we've
added the capability.
We can deploy these tests
out directly to a smartphone,
for instance, where somebody
who was walking down the street
can use your app.
The level of distraction in
the real world when people
are using mobile because
they've got stuff going on,
and they're getting social
notifications and stuff
like that-- it's
unbelievably high.
So you'll see even a beautifully
designed app that is well
designed to convey information.
People will see stuff that is
written right in front of them
on the screen, and
they just won't see it.
It's this cognitive
distraction thing
where they've got so much input
coming in when they're out
on the street that your
threshold for being obvious,
being intuitive,
being usable, is much,
much higher in the real world
than it is when you're doing
a design review
in some quiet room
where you project it up on
the wall and stuff like that.
That's not reality.
You need to be testing
stuff out in the real world.
KORY JEFFREY: Interesting.
So how do you get past that?
What are a few
little tidbits to get
past the design issue of having
so much information going in?
MICHAEL MACE: One thing
is the self-serving thing
of test stuff on UserTesting--
we'll set that aside.
KORY JEFFREY: That's
good to start with that.
MICHAEL MACE: I
think the big thing
is, being really sympathetic
to the situation that users
can be in and back stop them.
So for instance, we tested out
one of the major restaurant
finding sites to see, OK, let's
have somebody actually pick out
a restaurant and walk
to that restaurant.
Let's watch their whole progress
as they walk down the street
and all that sort of stuff.
We can turn on the
back side camera.
We watch them as they
walk down the street.
And what we found was,
one of the testers
ended up walking to a
restaurant that was closed.
And when we looked
back at the app,
it didn't notify them that
restaurant was closed.
But it was just in one
spot on one of the panels,
and it was just one word.
And they flipped past it
because they were in a hurry.
So if you're designing that
app, maybe what you want to do
is say, OK-- they went
from the app listing
to going to the map
function within the app.
So they're obviously
walking to the restaurant.
The restaurant is closed.
Maybe we want to pop up a dialog
that says hey, just to remind
you, the restaurant's closed.
Are you sure you want
to walk to it right now?
So you should assume
that people actually
don't see notifications
the first time.
And if, by monitoring
their behavior,
that tells you
that they probably
didn't get it the first time.
You need to repeat
it several times.
Sometimes that's going to
pester your users a little bit,
so give them the chance to
opt out of that if you're
getting to be too annoying.
But saving somebody 10
minutes when they're
walking down the street?
That's a huge deal
for a mobile app.
KORY JEFFREY: In
that instance, we
talked about using the back side
camera and access to location
and things like that.
Do you deal a lot with
people and permission flows
on how they ask people
what they can use and when,
so that they're able to
do these types of things?
MICHAEL MACE: We get
permission ahead of time
so the users understand
exactly what's going on.
We add a little red bar
at the top of the screen
when we're recording so
that they're reminded
that recording is going on.
And we also instruct them on
the things that they can't do.
The big thing is, you're not
allowed to interview somebody
else without permission.
So you can record yourself
and that's just fine.
But for instance, if
I had it running here
and I was pointing
the camera at you,
I would have to ask you
permission under US law.
Otherwise that's some horrible
wiretapping thing or something
like that.
It's awful, you don't
want to go there.
KORY JEFFREY: I guess the
example I want to touch on
is-- if I'm building
an app, right?
And I have to ask for
permissions for things?
Do you ever come
to a point where
you have to actually
design for when you only
get partial permissions?
MICHAEL MACE: Generally what
we do with the testers is we
get their permissions up front.
If you're asking for special
permission within the OS,
like your app is asking
for their location.
That permission
dialogue is going
to pop up the same as it would
any time other groups are
using that app.
So they'll just do that.
But for permission to
record their voice,
to record their image, take
information from their device?
We've already cleared
all that stuff with them.
KORY JEFFREY: Interesting.
OK, so we're at Founder World.
There's been thousands
of people walking here
over the past couple days.
There's a lot of exciting
technology on the floor.
What is it that you've seen
that's excited you here?
MICHAEL MACE: In
general the thing
that's got me the most
excited, not just here
but in the industry in
general, is all the VR
and 3D stuff that's going on.
I guess it's an
advantage of being
in the industry for a while.
I've seen some of
the former platforms
since they became
really prominent
like the graphical interface
and the Web itself.
The VR stuff-- when you combine
3D printing with all the VR
visualization we're
able to do now-- it
feels like the early
days of those platforms.
As we dig in, we're
starting to be
able to create some really
surprising non-intuitive stuff.
I had no idea.
We don't know yet what to
do with the technology.
To me, that's the most exciting
thing because these developers
are literally creating
the future right
now If I weren't
working at UserTesting,
I'd be going digging
into that stuff
right now because I think
it has huge potential.
KORY JEFFREY: Really cool.
So a relevant, but maybe
side track question--
do you have a favorite
Google technology?
MICHAEL MACE: It's hard to pick.
I don't want to offend
any of the teams,
but since I'm a
mobile guy-- Android.
KORY JEFFREY: Android?
MICHAEL MACE: Yeah.
Because it's done so
much and has so much
impact around the world.
KORY JEFFREY: Thank you
very much for joining us.
MICHAEL MACE: My
pleasure, thank you.
KORY JEFFREY: Lots of fun.
And thank you guys
for joining us.
We are on site at Founder
World in San Francisco.
[MUSIC PLAYING]